le passage du cyclone du mahdi les au
large de notre île les dégâts ont
finalement été limitée mais tous les
services de secours et de sécurité sont
restés mobilisés pendant plus de 24
heures
jean marc collienne et laurent fignon
était avec les pompiers de saint benoît
à lors du passage au plus près du
phénomène de notre île ils ont puis
suivre notamment les hommes de la
brigade nautique du service
départemental d'incendié reportage il
est 15h30 la journée a été calme
jusqu'ici au centre de secours de saint
benoît mais la pluie vient de
recommencer à tomber à l'intérieur le
lieutenant vas tu faire ce moment le
point avec ses hommes sur le dispositif
déployé bien donc nous sommes en début
d'après midi
dans la salle de réunion les pompiers de
saint benoît ont été rejoints par une
équipe ça sauvetage en eau ville
spécialisée dans les secours en rivière
l'équipe savent et nous mêmes eaux a
procédé à des reconnaissances se l'est
point stratégique pour cela donc
l'ensemble des bassins dont harris les
radios risque donc seront inspectés bons
messieurs c'est bon c'est parti pour les
reconnaissances
joannie madène fait partie de la brigade
nautique basée à saint leu face à la
menace cyclonique
elle a envoyé des hommes en appui à
saint benoît mais également à saint
pierre saint paul et sainte suzanne
codis cody ceci équipe nautique saint
benoît a parlé
l'équipe prend la direction du lait de
coco
la route est bien dégagé à part quelques
branches sur la chaussée le sien
mais le danger vient surtout des curieux
quand nous arrivons au radier dit lait
de coco
deux jeunes qui s'étaient approchés des
flots remonte précipitamment vers la
barrière
alors je dis pas cela dangereux là
l'intention parce que là sinon il monte
regardez à l'est pas mettre notre nez là
dedans enfin faut dire qu'on connaît
c'est pour ça qu'on est confiante qu'on
confiants après ces prêts en cas de
problème ça débute fort
c'est un endroit sensible ça très
sensible parce que
comme on a pu le constater il ya des
curieux qui viennent qui veulent voir
c'est normal
c'est l'humain et en plus il ya des gens
qui habitent de l'autre côté et ils
peuvent pas traverser un endroit qui est
très risqué là
la chaussée bonjour bien dans le miroir
pour voir de sécurité il ya des gens
dépendants qui passe est marié à quand
même mais bon ça va
[Musique]
y'a rien ok allez bonne journée
nous allons nous diriger vers bassin la
paix basse à la mer pour voir plus ou
moins s'il ya des imprudents
pierre qu'on était venu c'était au
niveau de la balle baromètre était le
truc l'arrêté via plus haut 1
il a défendu un peu mais c'est très
dangereux encore l'adjudant-chef baden
aperçoit alors deux jeunes
perché au dessus du torrent
qui a toujours les imprudences comme ça
doit toujours oui
si on tombe à l'eau il ya un conseil
le fatah paul et essayer si on n'est pas
de blesser de ne pas s'affoler et de se
rapprocher un maximum de la berre et
surtout ne pas se mettre de face a
toujours sur le dos face que de façon va
prendre si elle est en bacs
comme je le dis on va prendre la tête au
dessus sur le dos avec les pieds on va
pouvoir analyser et se dirigeait avec
nos mains le groupe décide alors de
descendre vers le bas ce que tout le
monde remonte là
d'accord on va voir un train
on speed un peu
en bas l'eau se jette dans le bassin
avec une puissance impressionnante et
juste au bord l'adjudant-chef madène
découvre un petit groupe de touristes
espagnols besoin de rester là donc il
faudrait peut-être là comme vous êtes la
cible la roche est très glissante j'ai
pas poli ça c'est juste la prévention
on ne réalise jamais tout à fait majeur
elle tombe là peu à peu remonté la
après avoir inspecté les bassins les
plus fréquentés de la commune l'équipe
de la brigade nautique prend la
direction du bord de mer à l'embouchure
de la rivière des roches
rien à signaler la houle relativement
modéré n'a pas attiré le spectateur il
est 17h embouchure de la rivière des
roches fait le feu l'endroit où nous
n'avons pas vu de spectateur imprudent
dernière étape de l'inspection de la
brigade nautique retour à prévoir au
centre de secours les pompiers espèrent
que la foire il sera aussi calme
quatorze pompiers sont mobilisés
aujourd'hui au centre de secours de
saint benoît qui devrait intervenir dans
tout l'est de l'île de sainte rose à
bras panon en passant par la plaine des
palmistes et bien sûr ils ne doivent pas
se l'ingérer de conséquence du mauvais
temps
oui disent j'ai reçu c'est bon j'ai fait
sortir dans ce quartier pour liliane
une femme de 35 ans qu'ils étaient déçus
sortie s'ils sortent ici cf
[Musique]
ortiz sergio salma pour subir la jemaye
prendront une robe noire arrivés sur
place les pompiers découvrent un arbre
que le vent a couché en travers de la
chaussée juste à l'entrée d'une
habitation en une dizaine de minutes et
quelques coups de tronçonneuse
les habitants pourront à nouveau sortir
de chez eux
[Musique]
une demi heure plus tard alors que la
nuit tombe
les pompiers sont appelés pour un
accident de la circulation à saint-andré
sur la chaussée rendue glissante
deux voitures sont entrées en collision
à petit bazar un secteur où les
accidents sont fréquents par temps de
pluie
au total les pompiers de saint benoît ne
seront intervenus que quatre fois
pendant l'alertent près cyclonique pour
des incidents liés au mauvais temps
il est 20 heures l'alerté près
cyclonique est levé depuis deux heures
maintenant mais quatorze pompiers vont
rester mobilisés toute la nuit ici à
saint-benoît prêts à intervenir à tout
moment
après un épisode cyclonique qui
heureusement n'aura eu aucune
conséquence grave dans les stades